T
SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL.
HERE FOR A REACTION,
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND SENATE
CANDIDATE COME ALONG WITH FORMER
DIRECTOR IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, TOM HOMAN.
TOM, LET ME START WITH YOU.
BECAUSE WE HEAR THESE STORIES,
THERE IS NOT A LOT OF VISUALS,
PEOPLE DON'T SEE IT SO MUCH.
YOU CAN KIND OF BECOME AN -- OFE
TRAGEDY OF IT ALL.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
WE DON'T SEE IT ON TV LIKE WE DO
WITH UKRAINE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IT HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS.
WHERE DO YOU -- WHERE IS THIS
NOW?
WHERE DO YOU SEE IT GOING?
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK BIDEN CAN
OR WILL DO, WHICH I THINK AT
THIS POINT IS NOTHING.
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOU ROCKED IT.
YOU ARE RIGHT AND EVERY POINT
YOU MADE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO FIX THIS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN IN POWER -- THEY HAVEN'T
DONE A SINGLE THING.
NOTHING.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING TO SECURE
THE BORDER.
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE DONE IS
HAVE, HOW QUICKLY CAN WE PROCESS
MIGRANTS RELEASE?
RIGHT NOW THEY ARE LOOKING AT
$900 MILLION SO THEY CAN PROMPT
THIS RELEASE QUICKER.
AND WHEN YOU PROCESS AND RELEASE
QUICKER, THAT JUST BRINGS MORE.
AND YOUR POINT -- LET ME MAKE
ONE MORE POINT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KEPT
SAYING THAT THE POLICY IS
INHUMANE.
MORE MIGRANTS HAVE DIED UNDER
THE FIRST YEAR AT JOE BIDEN ON
U.S. SOIL THAN ANY YEAR I CAN
REMEMBER.
A RECORD NUMBER.
OVER 100,000 AMERICANS HAVE DIED
OF OVERDOSE OF FAT AND ALL.
HIS POLICY IS INHUMANE AND THEY
ARE KILLING PEOPLE.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT REMINDER.
ATTORNEY GENERAL, YOU'VE BEEN
DOWN TO THE BORDER.
THIS IS A HUMAN CATASTROPHE.
WE SEE IT, IT IS GETTING WORSE,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SHOCKED.
THERE IS A WAR GOING ON AROUND
THE WORLD.
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF VIRUSES
BEYOND COVID.
WHAT DID YOU SEE AT THE BORDER?
ARE THEY GETTING ANY KIND OF A
HANDLE OF IT?
THERE'S NOMINEE, THERE'S NO
ASSISTANCE.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING DOWN THERE?
>> TO MAKE HIM A THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME ON.
I LITERALLY WAS IN DOUGLAS TODAY
AND THE DOUGLAS SECTOR, JUST IN
FEBRUARY, THERE WAS NEARLY
40,000 PEOPLE, EITHER THEY GIVE
UP THAT TRIED TO CROSS THAT
SECTOR.
ONLY A THOUSAND OF THEM WERE
TURNED AWAY.
THIS IS HAVING A DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON OUR COUNTRY.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS WE NOW, CONGRESS HAS
BEEN BROKEN FOR SO LONG FOR THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT HAVE
DAMAGED OUR COUNTRY.
BUT WHEN YOU COMBINE THAT WITH
THE CLOWN SHOW THAT IS THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE, IT IS DEVASTATING.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
WE TALK ABOUT THESE NUMBERS AND
SOMETIMES YOU GET NUMB TO THEM,
BUT LITERALLY, PEOPLE'S
DAUGHTERS, NIECES, NEPHEWS ARE
BEING KILLED.
THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF DEATH
NOW AMONGST YOUNG PEOPLE MUST
FATTEN ALL AND DRUG OVERDOSES.
AMERICANS ARE PAYING THE COST
AND IT IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
HAVE LED THE LAWSUIT ON TITLE 42
AGAINST THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, WHY WE SUED THEM
OVER THE INABILITY OR
UNWILLINGNESS TO FOLLOW THE LAW
AND DEPORT PEOPLE.
SO WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
DONE IS DECRIMINALIZED AND
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE BREAKING THE
LAW.
>> THAT IS A GREAT POINT.
OBVIOUSLY AS THE CHAOS GOOD GETS
WORSE, IT MEANS THERE WILL BE
EVEN MORE ADDITIONAL CRIME, MORE
SEX TRAFFICKING, MORE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, MORE DRUGS COMING
ACROSS.
IT IS BAD ENOUGH WHEN THERE ARE
SOME SECURITY, BUT WHEN THERE IS
COMPLETE CHAOS, IT JUST
EMBOLDENS THE ACTORS IN THIS
EVEN MORE, DOESN'T IT?
>> YES, IT DOES.
YOU ARE RIGHT ON THOSE POINTS.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY BEAR THEY'VE
ARTIE ENCOUNTERED 1.2 MILLION.
THEY ARE ON A SCALE RIGHT NOW TO
BEAT LAST YEAR'S NUMBERS, WHICH
IS HISTORIC.
THEY ARE GOING TO BLOW THEM OUT
OF THE WATER.
EVEN WITH TITLE 42 AND PLACE.
THERE'S BEEN 60,000 GOT A WAYS
JUST LAST MONTH.
67,000 PEOPLE ENTER THIS COUNTRY
THAT WEREN'T ARRESTED.
AND THEY COME FROM 157 DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES.
IF YOU DON'T THINK THAT ANY OF
THOSE 67,000 CAME FROM A COUNTRY
THAT SUPPORTS TERRORISM, THAN
THEY ARE BEING IGNORANT.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
IF THEY LIFT TITLE 42, THAT'S
67,000 -- IT'S GOING TO SWELL TO
OVER 100,000 A MONTH.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE
ARE.
SUCH A SCARED EVERY AMERICAN.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS CREATED
A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS THAT
I'VE NEVER SEEN.
>> THAT IS THE KEY PHRASE, TOM.
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THIS IS NOT AN ACCIDENT.
IT IS NOT A MISTAKE.
THEY ARE NOT CLUELESS.
THERE IS NOW CLEARLY -- IT SEEMS
TO BE DELIBERATE.
THAT THIS IS POLICY.
IT IS NOT LIKE COME ABOUT POLICY
THAT NO ONE IS LISTENING TO.
THIS IS THE POLICY.
WHAT COULD THE END GAME BE HERE
WHEN YOU'VE GOT A POLICY THAT IS
AS MONSTROUS AS THIS?
>> TAMMY, WHEN YOU COMBINE WHAT
IS HAPPENING ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, NATIONAL SECURITY FAT,
THE INCREASE IN CRIME, WHAT WE
ARE SEEN AS AN ATTEMPT BY THE
LEFT AND -- THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY
TRYING TO SOCIALIZE OUR ECONOMY,
NATIONALIZE OUR ELECTION, AND
OVERWHELM OUR SYSTEM AND OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
I THINK PEOPLE BECOME MORE
DEPENDENT ON CENTRAL AUTHORITY.
THIS IS THE NEO-MARXIST
PLAYBOOK.
WE SEE THIS FROM EVERYWHERE --
INCREASED CRIME IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS BEAR THAT IS WHY
THE FIGHTING MUST STOP.
>> Tammy: THANK GOO